Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and yes there
was new Walking Dead despite the Oscars going
down.
And it was an amazing episode.
We got a deep dive into Daryl just like Michonne
a couple weeks ago and Beth broke out the
party games for a very special first moment
she’d been waiting to have.
Quick shoutout for my weekly giveaway.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
each week just to say thank you to you guys
for being so awesome I randomly pick one subscriber
from the comments to give a $20 amazon giftcard
to.
I’ll announce who it is in my Q&A video
tomorrow.
But all you have to do to participate is be
a subscriber and leave a comment.
And be nice.
So let’s do our top 5 moments from the episode
first and then I’ll do my review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go, Number 5 - The opening Scene in
the Trunk.
The combination of it being super dark and
stormy and them just listening to Walkers
pile on top of the car was so intense and
just the perfect way to start an episode.
I loved that when day finally came they just
got out shrugged it off and continued down
the road.
Just like it was any other day in Walker Paradise.
Number 4 - Beth’s First Drink.
Of course the last thing left in the apocalypse
would be Peach Schnapps.
No one wants to drink it, no matter how desperate
they are for booze.
This was actually a funny scene because Beth
was so determined to get that first drink.
Until she broke down I actually kind of thought
that it was only because she wanted a drink.
But really, she NEEDED the drink.
I think that moment where Daryl smashed the
bottle was him just helping her keep her dignity
a little.
Like he was genuinely trying to be nice.
Being nice for Daryl isn’t quite the same
thing as being nice for you or me.
But it’s the thought that counts.
Number 3 - Drinking Game.
How awesome was it that not only did they
find Daryl’s Dad’s cabin, but that it
was packed with Moonshine.
It really makes you feel like geographically
they haven’t traveled that far.
I kept getting a hook up vibe from the two
of them and the drinking game, which was hilarious,
seemed like it was all about Beth putting
a move on Daryl after she got too drunk.
I was really happy when thing’s didn’t
go down that way.
Instead though it led to something so much
cooler.
Number 2 - Daryl Loses His Shit.
Daryl is a hard man to read.
Norman Reedus does such a good job of playing
emotions under the skin.
You could kind of tell what Daryl was thinking
based on his grunts and shrugs.
So Beth getting him to finally admit how bad
he felt was really satisfying.
I kind of viewed all of these cabin scenes
as his version of the scene Michonne got two
weeks ago with the flashbacks to her baby.
Although Daryl opted to resolve his feelings
about the past in much more spectacular fashion.
and my Number 1 moment no surprise here - Burning
Down The House.
Let me know if you also feel like Beth has
become the collective consciousness of their
little group.
She was always the moral core, but now she’s
kind of operating Daryl like a finger puppet.
Not in a bad way.
But she was basically his psychiatrist throughout
the entire Cabin part of the episode.
She identifies his problems and then helps
him find closure.
Look how much she’s grown up.
And she can even kill the shit out of walkers.
I love that she said, I’m not like those
other girls.
But I survived.
Beth is officially cooler than Daryl Dixon,
at least until Daryl finds another poncho.
But let me know what your favorite moment
from the episode was in the comments below
and if Maggie and Sasha’s group are also
in the episode next week do you expect them
to meet up?
I think they will, just like Carl and Rick
met up with Michonne when they were in the
same episode.
Overall the episode was A plus amazing.
Really, this is the first A plus I think I’ve
ever given any episode this season.
I was watching this while I also had the Oscars
on in the background and if you skipped Oscars
for this I can tell you, you made the right
call.
I love how Walking Dead has used these post-prison
group based episodes to give us all this new
information about major characters pasts.
Like learning what teenage Daryl was like.
Turns out it wasn’t all that pleasant, but
I think we all already suspected that.
Beth on the other hand has been a wonderful
surprise, I’m so glad that she’s a badass
now, it just means there will be so many more
opportunities for comedy with these two.
I really hope that they continue to have a
special bond after meeting back up with other
prison people.
Just like Beth said, she’s different than
everyone else, so I don’t think that she’ll
end up like Carol or Laurie or even Michonne.
Right now, she seems like she’s going to
be the one to take over Hershel’s role as
the moral center of the show.
Even if all the groups don’t completely
reunite by the end of the season.
Lizzie on the other hand is turning into something
of a female governor.
We need to keep our eyes peeled on her.
Love or hate the episode, be sure to sound
off in the comments..
I’m also going to try and post an Oscar
Winners analysis video late late tonight.
Q&A video for Walking Dead with giveaway winner
will post tomorrow night.
Right now click here for my Oscar video and
click here for that Q&A.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!